i think if you liked season one all of
the you know
drama and humor and and music
that people sort of um fell in love with
in season one is only heightened i think
in season two
so many kids would kill to get into a
school like this but there's one thing
they don't have
hard to picture doing a show without you
we're adding a bunch of
awesome new characters that totally add
to the show and
um also i think you kind of get to see
a more in-depth look at some of the
characters that we just didn't have time
to look at in season one
so um i'm super excited about that i'm
also really excited about the music i
think
the songs are really incredible in
season two we've already got a taste of
some of the music
coming a season two of high school
musical the musical the series with
olivia rodrigo
and joshua bassett's duet even when the
best
[Music]
could the track part at where things are
headed for the paris characters
nini and ricky who struggle with their
long-distance relationship
long-distance relationships are no fun
but i think the writers of the show did
a really interesting job of or
portraying that and there's some really
cute moments in their long-distance
relationship
that i think fans will like to see um
but you know you'll have to stay tuned
there's there's many bumps in the road
sounds like your girlfriend wants some
space let me know if you're looking for
one who doesn't
like season one she was really finding
her voice and finding her footing and i
think
in season two she's sort of finding out
what really makes her happy which i
think is such an important part of your
identity as well
so it was really cool to um sort of
portray that journey this semester we
are entering
the alan menken awards for high school
musical theater
and we are doing beauty and the beast
i'm excited to do beauty and the beast
this year it's one of my
favorite musicals it's actually the
first musical that i was ever in like in
real life as a child i played a coat
hanger and a sheep in vegan beasts and i
was like three years old so it's kind of
full circle to be able to
do that musical another musical
milestone
her first album sour dropping may 21st
[Music]
sour is definitely like a slice of my 17
year old heart i wrote about everything
i was
feeling and and going through and you
know all the insecurities i was having
and all
feelings of sadness and anger and all of
these things that you know i don't often
like talk about in my daily life but
it's so fun that i get to sort of
express that in my songwriting
so it definitely was therapeutic
[Music]
i love writing a sad breakup ballad
i literally i wrote like breakup songs
when i was 12 years old and i didn't
have a crush on anyone like i'm obsessed
with them
um but i'm really proud of
this sort of diversity and sour
there's you know a bunch of different
genres of music that are kind of
compacted into the 11 songs that make up
the album
and the 18 year old singer is already
getting praised by her idols like taylor
swift
i don't know i've just been really
touched by the way that
so many um you know more established
artists have really
welcomed me into the music industry and
gone out of their way to welcome me
i think it's just like a really a
testament of how kind they are you know
it takes like a really
awesome person to like you know see
somebody coming up and feel the need to
to make them feel seen and hurt so um
yeah that's been
one of my you know favorite parts of
this whole um
process and i can't wait to like meet
people in real life too
soon when you know everything's safe
[Music]
again
you